(upbeat jazzy music)
- Where on Earth
are Dana and Julia?
- [Group Of Girls] Go away!
Get your bald eagles outta here!
(punches)
- [Dana And Julia] Hip bump!
- I can't wait to
have hair on my bush.
- I wish my mum
wasn't dead so I could
see if she had a hairy bush.
'Cause they're hereditary.
- My mum has a big bush
so I'm a lucky-duck.
- Ugh, you don't have to
rub it in my face, Julia.
- Ew, I would never rub my
mum's bush in your face!
(laughs)
- Grow!
I hate you!
(gasps loudly)
You're a turd-burglar!
You have pubic hair
and you didn't tell me.
- Just one, and it's little.
- No!
That's not fair.
You can't have hair
down there without me.
Let me see it again.
- No, it's private.
- We promised each
other we would develop
at the same time!
- Hey look, guys.
I made a booger wall
and I color coordinated it,
from darkest green
on up to light green.
I'm gon' make a museum in here.
Mah own booger museum.
- Ew, Michael Jackson,
were you listening to us?
- I did hear you.
If you wanna get rid of that
unwanted hair down there,
you gonna have to brazilian.
- [Dana And Julia]
What's brazilian?
- It's when you your
vajayjay form front to back
and all around the side.
My two mums give
each other brazilian
waxes at home
to save money.
That's what they tell
me when they have
the door locked.
- So, all you need is wax?
- Julia, you have to
take your underwear off
so I can get to that hair!
- I don't want to anymore.
Can't I just keep
it for the holidays?
- No!
It's not fair and you know it.
- Fine, take my pube,
just leave me be.
- Ew, it smells!
I'm just kidding.
(dripping wax)
(panicked screams)
- What's going on in there?!
I smell smoke.
(laughing)
- Oh my god!
Your mum does have the biggest
bush in the whole world!
- Don't look at me!
- Sorry, mummy.
- Julia, you are
severely punished
and Dana, you're not
allowed to come over here
for a month.
I'm calling your father,
hopefully he's not chanting
the names of the divine
or whatever the fuck he does.
(door slams)
- (Laughs) Your mum's bush!
- Oh my god, your
ponytail's gone.
- And your little hair is gone.
- Best friends forever.
- Developing together.
Oh my god, I almost forgot.
When I was brazilianing you,
I saw you have hair
all over your butt.
- No I don't.
- Oh my god, you
have two scrotums!
- [Dana And Julia] Hip bump!
(upbeat, light hip hop)
(upbeat, jazzy music)